[Musica]
prendiamo un movimento semplice un
movimento come questo
può essere un movimento per andare a
prendere un bicchiere d'acqua e quindi
spente da un
bisogno
essenziale lasciate però potrebbe essere
anche movimento per prendere un
bicchiere di vino il terzo bicchiere di
vino di una serata passata con amici
e poi magari bisogna tornare a casa a
fare un pezzo di autostrada
e su questa decisione
è incombono
le nostre conoscenze sugli effetti
dell'alcol la nostra genetica anche la
propensione quindi che sappiamo essere
legata ad alcuni geni a rischio
anche i rapporti inter divi inter
individuali che abbiamo in generale
nostre conoscenze
insomma la nostra personalità se
vogliamo anche ma fino a che punto siamo
condizionati da tutto questo esiste
qualcosa che poi ci dica che siamo
davvero liberi di decidere se andare
oppure no a prendere sto bicchiere di
vino come ma ne discutiamo adesso ne
discutiamo
adesso perché
una serie di ricerche hanno portato una
serie dei neuroscienziati di filosofi
anche a concludere che no noi non siamo
liberi che il libero arbitrio tema che
ha attraversato la filosofia fin dalla
nascita direi di questa di pensare
dell'uomo sì ci porta a concludere che
no che non siamo che non siamo liberi
che tutta un'illusione quella che noi
abbiamo di essere liberi e su che cosa
si basa questa conclusione si basa su
una serie di esperimenti che hanno tutti
grosso modo lo stesso schema anche se
diversi modi di
registrare l'attività cerebrale più
semplice che vi mostro più in dettaglio
è questo che vedete qui c'è una persona
che deve schiacciare un pulsante e
decide di schiacciare questo pulsante
quando pensa lui di farlo non c'è nessun
obbligo deve soltanto prender note in
quel momento in cui decide di
schiacciare il pulsante di qual è il
tempo di qual è il tempo su un
cronometro oppure che cosa sta
succedendo in quel momento
e mentre si effettua questo questa prova
si registrano delle attività cerebrali
per esempio in questo modo con una
l'elettroencefalogramma ecco quello che
vedete dallo schema sotto è che c'è un
punto m che quello in cui soggetto
comincia a schiacciare il pulsante e c'è
un momento di che quello in cui decide
di schiacciare il pulsante e c'è un
intervallo fra i due mondi intervallo
molto più lungo c'è nel momento in cui
quella curva comincia a salire quella
curva è l'attività di preparazione del
movimento pd come se il cervello sapesse
prima di me prima di me che sto
effettuando esami che cosa sto per fare
e questa diciamo questo schema è stato
ripetuto anche con la risonanza
magnetica funzionale
in cui si vedono qui con le aree rosse
le aree che sono connesse alla attività
motoria di preparazione motore quelle in
verde che invece vengono prima che il
soggetto abbia deciso di effettuare il
movimento in questo caso anche prima che
abbia deciso di farlo con la mano destra
allora la sinistra c'è stato anche poi
una sequela di questo studio qua
addirittura con registrazione
intracerebrale della attività
questi esperimenti possono essere anche
interpretati in maniera diversa io penso
perché il cervello
in realtà ci informa spesso con ritardo
di quello che sta facendo ad esempio
provate a fare una cosa molto semplice
toccarvi con la punta del dito la punta
del naso e puntate la vostra attenzione
sul momento in cui sentite la
sensibilità sulla punta del dito è sulla
punta del naso
sono convinto che vi appare
contemporaneo e invece al cervello
l'impulso che arriva dal la punta del
naso e molto precedente di 250
millisecondi rispetto a quello che
proviene dalla punta del dito
e questo per potrebbe venire anche nella
preparazione motoria perché no noi molte
attività che facciamo le facciamo
automaticamente dal frenare
improvvisamente quando siamo in
autostrada è anche ad attività più
complesse e
l'osservazione dei pazienti ci rende
evidente che questa dissociazione fra
attività volontaria e attività invece
automatica e
supportata anche da diverse aree
cerebrali ad esempio c'è una situazione
nella quale la persona non è in grado di
eseguire gesti semplici tipo per esempio
soffiare no ma li esegue se c'è un
contesto adatto per esempio se vedi
importato davanti una torta in cui c'è
una candelina e bisogna per spegnerla ma
questo capita anche nel linguaggio anche
di fronte a una cosa cosi complessa come
linguaggio la le capacità automatiche
rimangono per parecchio tempo e anzi
sono le prime che
vengono salvate anche in caso di un
gravissimo disturbo del linguaggio
ricordo un caso che non poteva
dimenticare
di fronte a una persona che aveva un
gravissimo disturbo del linguaggio nel
senso che non capaci di dire il suo nome
ma neppure di dire il nome di nessun
oggetto di uso comune neppure di
ripetere quello che io le chiedevo di
ripetere beh questa persona aveva
cominciato a poter contare quindi ricevo
1 e lei diceva
23 ma poi si ferma lì e allora mi viene
in mente di dire signora proviamo questo
ave maria e lei attacco grazia plena
dominus 3 con benedicta turi mulieribus
vene l'ictus è una persona prelato che
non aveva fatto oltre la quinta
elementare ma evidentemente per la era
una cosa molto praticata la vicina di
letto si alzò di scatto e disse miracolo
non era un miracolo dovetti calmare un
po gli astanti diciamo bene
sempre in ambito clinico quello che noi
possiamo anche osservare un fenomeno
veramente particolare quello il
cosiddetto all arto alieno o arto
anarchico cioè un braccio che fa quello
che noi non vorremmo che facesse ad
esempio un caso che ho osservato una
persona messa davanti da un libro o un
libro sfogliava le pagine di questo
libro però mi aveva detto no devi
leggere quello che c'è scritto non devi
sfogliare le pagine
lo sapeva quindi cosa doveva fare allora
con l'altra mano andava a fermare cerca
a cercare di fermare la farà a meno che
faceva questo gesto automatico
tornando poi al problema più in generale
noi abbiamo delle decisioni che
riguardano
delle discriminazioni percettive
ad esempio che dobbiamo decidere di
attraversare la strada
guardiamo destra e sinistra vediamo che
sta arrivando un automobile
facciamo il calcolo della velocità
dell'automobile e della nostra capacità
di andare velocemente dall'altra parte
decidiamo se attraversare o non
attraversare la strada e poi però ci
sono altre decisioni che vengono
chiamate economiche in realtà non
c'entra non necessariamente anche un
investimento ma sono tutte decisioni in
cui noi aspettiamo di avere un ritorno
positivo in relazione al raggiungimento
di un obiettivo che può essere per
esempio una migliore salute se decidiamo
di a smettere di fumare iniziare una
dieta quel giorno stesso perché staremo
meglio o iniziare un programma
di studi diverso
ecco cosa hanno tutti in comune questo
tipo di decisioni che francamente
difficile
pensare che non siano libere e non siano
il risultato di quello che è la nostra
personalità che ha certo dai
condizionamenti ma che alla fine ci
lascia uno spazio di libertà beh tutte
queste decisioni
hanno in comune
il fatto di
sorgere dal dalla l'elemento
responsabilità responsabilità e libertà
sono strettamente connesse in questo
caso non è il cervello
dell'individuo da solo che determina la
crocetta ashley scelta ma il fatto
quindi che il cervello di una persona
sia in relazione con gli altri cervelli
della sua comunità ecco allora in questo
caso in questo contesto
in cui c'è poco di automatico ma c'è
molto di riflessione sulla propria vita
sulla vita degli altri e su come la
nostra vita influenza la vita degli
altri
in questo noi davvero siamo liberi ed è
lì che
si esercita la nostra libertà e il
nostro libero arbitrio di razza
[Applauso]
[Musica]